It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
目前正值授粉高峰期，我的业务也在飞速发展。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢里人声鼎沸、嗡嗡作响，我的网络连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个机不可失的优惠。今天就来探索 Google Fi Wireless 的套餐吧。需另付税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. In recent years, there's been a worldwide increase in disasters, mass violence, and terrorism around the world. These events often come with loss of life, leaving many children experiencing both trauma and grief, which take a toll on their development. Disasters leave many children struggling with mental health conditions such as depression, anxiety, and PTSD, as they also struggle with their grief. Furthermore, when the grief is due to an event that is widely covered by media, children and their families often have difficulty navigating their personal recovery and healing separate from that of the community. So what do we know about children's experiences of trauma and grief?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。近年来，全球范围内的灾难、大规模暴力事件和恐怖主义事件有所增加。这些事件往往伴随着生命的消逝，导致许多儿童经历创伤和悲痛，进而对其发育造成影响。灾难让许多儿童在应对悲痛的同时，还要挣扎于抑郁、焦虑和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）等心理健康问题。此外，当悲痛源于媒体广泛报道的事件时，儿童及其家庭往往很难在独立于社区整体的情况下，去处理个人的康复和治愈过程。那么，我们对儿童经历的创伤和悲痛有哪些了解呢？
How does such events influence their development both in the near term and beyond? How can parents, caregivers, and therapists help children who have lived through floods, wildfires, hurricanes, war, and other traumatic events? What can be done for parents and other caregivers who themselves are suffering as they try to help their kids recover and thrive? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills, coming to you from Denver at APA 2025, the National Convention of the American Psychological Association. My guest today is Dr. Robin Gerwitch, an emeritus professor in the Duke University Department of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences and the Center for Child and Family Health. She is a recognized expert in understanding and supporting children in the aftermath of trauma and disasters.
此类事件如何影响他们在近期及以后的发展？父母、照顾者和治疗师该如何帮助那些经历过洪水、野火、飓风、战争和其他创伤性事件的儿童？对于那些在努力帮助孩子恢复和茁壮成长时，自身也正承受痛苦的父母和其他照顾者，我们可以做些什么？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（APA）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），在丹佛的 2025 年美国心理学协会全国大会（APA 2025）为您现场报道。我今天的嘉宾是罗宾·格维茨博士（Dr. Robin Gerwitch），她是杜克大学精神病学与行为科学系以及儿童与家庭健康中心的荣誉退休教授。她是理解和支持经历过创伤和灾难的儿童领域的公认专家。
Since the Oklahoma City bombing in 1995, Dr. Gerwitch has focused much of her clinical work, training, and research on improving the outcomes and increasing resilience in children who have experienced. trauma or lived through crises, including terrorism, natural disasters, and stressors related to military deployment. She has served on state and national committees and task forces, including the National Commission on Children and Disaster's Subcommittee on Human Services Recovery. Dr. Gerwitch is one of the first people we at APA reach out to after disasters to help us advise families and children who are trying to cope. Dr. Gerwitch has co-authored book chapters, scientific journal articles, and public education materials on the topics of trauma, resilience, psychological first aid, terrorism, disasters, and preparedness. Dr. Gerwitch, thank you for joining me today at APA 2025.
自 1995 年俄克拉荷马城爆炸案以来，格维茨博士的大部分临床工作、培训和研究都聚焦于改善经历过创伤或经历过危机（包括恐怖主义、自然灾害以及与军事部署相关的压力源）的儿童的预后，并增强其抗逆力。她曾担任多个州级和国家级委员会及工作组的成员，包括“国家儿童与灾难委员会人类服务复苏小组委员会”。格维茨博士是我们在灾难发生后联系的第一批专家之一，她协助我们为那些努力应对危机的家庭和儿童提供建议。格维茨博士合著了多部图书章节、科学期刊文章以及关于创伤、抗逆力、心理急救、恐怖主义、灾难和防灾备灾主题的公众教育材料。格维茨博士，非常感谢您今天在 APA 2025 上接受我的采访。
It is my pleasure to be with you today, Kim. So you've worked with and studied children affected by everything from terrorism to natural disasters. What are some common emotional responses you see in kids after traumatic events? So when we think about these disasters, whether it's terrorism or whether it is natural disasters, we need to recognize that children will have a variety of responses. And they start as young as infancy and go all the way through the child age span, all the way up to that 18-year-old, 19-year-old. We see challenges in sleep problems.
很高兴今天能和你在一起，金。那么，你曾与受恐怖主义至自然灾害等各种事件影响的儿童一起工作并对此进行研究。在经历创伤事件后，你在孩子们身上看到的一些常见情绪反应有哪些？所以当我们想到这些灾难时，无论是恐怖主义还是自然灾害，我们需要认识到儿童会有各种各样的反应。它们从婴儿期就开始了，一直贯穿整个儿童年龄段，直到 18 岁、19 岁。我们看到睡眠问题带来的挑战。
We see problems related to interactions with the people in their lives, whether it is irritability with their parents and having more meltdowns and being more defiant to being more clingy and withdrawing. We also see children as they get older, have more conflict with their peers, or feeling that they're being bullied when they never were before or actually beginning to bully when they didn't do that before. We may see problems in terms of school performance. And I think sometimes parents, if they don't know that, and teachers too, if I don't know that learning is going to be impacted, then I don't understand why I can't give 50 problems when 25 could do when I'm really struggling
我们看到与他们生活中人们互动相关的问题，无论是对父母易怒、情绪崩溃更多、更具反叛性，还是变得更加黏人、退缩。随着年龄的增长，我们还看到儿童与同龄人产生更多冲突，或者觉得被欺凌（尽管以前从未有过），亦或是开始欺凌他人（尽管以前没有这样做过）。我们可能会看到学业表现方面的问题。我想有时如果父母不知道这一点，老师也是一样，如果我不知道学习会受到影响，那么当我在经历真正挣扎时，
after a disaster. So sometimes we see a dip in school grades, and that's to be expected, and it should pop back if we give them the emotional support that they need. There's a small number, Kim, I think this is just fascinating, that actually the grades get better. And who calls school and says, hey, please, I need mental health services. My kids' grades have improved tremendously, right? But if you think about disasters, they're out of our control. And if I study all my free time, I can control that. And it's that control that ends up being leading to better school grades. But there's a cost.
在灾难发生后，如果25道题就能达到效果，我就不明白为什么我非得布置50道题。所以有时我们会看到学校成绩下降，这是意料之中的，只要我们给予他们所需的情感支持，成绩就应该会回升。金，有一小部分人，我认为这太迷人了，他们的成绩实际上变好了。谁会打电话给学校说：“嘿，求求你了，我需要心理健康服务。我孩子的成绩提高得太惊人了，对吧？”但如果你想想灾难，它们是我们无法控制的。如果我把我所有的空闲时间都用来学习，我就可以控制这一点。正是这种控制最终导致了更好的学校成绩。但这是有代价的。
Usually as my school grades go up, I'm not getting together with my friends. I'm not wanting to go to dance or soccer. I'm not wanting to do other activities. And so there's a cost. So we should be equally worried. Right. It's not a good sign. It's not a good sign.
通常，随着我的学校成绩上升，我不再和朋友聚会了。我不想去跳舞或踢足球了。我不想进行其他活动了。所以这是有代价的。因此，我们应该同样感到担忧。没错。这不是一个好兆头。这不是一个好兆头。
And I think we see behavior changes, as I said, you know, we see children after these events, both terrorism as well as natural disasters, school shootings, other kinds of tragic events. And we see problems with attention, problems with concentration. We see more active behaviors. We see irritability and mood swings. and we've been conditioned by the pharmaceutical industry. If your child is showing all these things, talk to your doctor, talk to him about free samples of Adderostrater, ors, orther, ritalin, the problem is that those kinds of behaviors
正如我所说，我认为我们看到了行为的变化，你知道的，在这些事件（包括恐怖主义以及自然灾害、校园枪击事件、其他类型的悲惨事件）之后，我们看到了儿童的注意力问题、集中力问题。我们看到了更多活跃的行为。我们看到了易怒和情绪波动。我们已经被制药行业驯化了。如果你的孩子表现出所有这些迹象，去和你的医生谈谈，跟他谈谈 Adderall、利他林等药物的免费样品。问题在于，那些类型的行为
are exactly what we see with children that have experienced these events. And then you have children that truly have ADHD that also have experienced disasters. So we as psychologists need to step up and say, hey, hey, let's wait a second. Let's make sure that we're looking at true ADHD and not reactions to an event that just took place. So psychologists really have a critical role to play to help educate not only families and do better jobs with assessment, but to educate our physician partners and to educate education systems so they're not referring an entire classroom of third graders for ADHD evals. So we do see some of that.
正是我们在经历过这些事件的儿童身上看到的行为。然后你会发现，有些真正患有 ADHD 的儿童也经历过灾难。因此，作为心理学家，我们必须站出来说：“嘿，等等，等一下。我们要确保我们看到的是真正的 ADHD，而不是对刚刚发生事件的反应。”因此，心理学家确实可以发挥关键作用，不仅帮助教育家庭并做好评估工作，还要教育我们的医师伙伴和教育系统，这样他们就不会把一整间三年级教室的学生都转介去做 ADHD 评估了。所以我们确实看到了其中的一些现象。
And the best treatment for trauma for kids is psychotherapy. Let's talk a little bit more about those treatments because you've been instrumental in developing and adapting parent-child interaction therapy and other treatments. So how do those models work? Why are they so effective? So, yes. There have, there are, I think about when I entered this field more decades ago than I want to think about how little we knew about interventions and where we are in 2025. And psychologists have really led the way on scientifically backed interventions. And we know now that whether you are an infant or a teen or anywhere in between, there are effective treatments. We have the science to back that up.
对于儿童来说，创伤的最佳治疗方法是心理治疗。让我们多谈谈这些治疗方法，因为你在开发和调整亲子互动疗法及其他治疗方法方面发挥了重要作用。那么这些模式是如何运作的？为什么它们如此有效？是的。回想我进入这个领域的年代——比我愿意承认的要多出好几个星期——我们对干预措施知之甚少，而再看看我们在 2025 年所处的位置，我认为有很多变化。心理学家在科学支持的干预措施方面确实引领了潮流。我们现在知道，无论你是婴儿、青少年还是介于两者之间的任何年龄段，都有有效的治疗方法。我们有科学依据来支持这一点。
My particular area when I'm looking outside of the universal like psychological first aid is parent-child interaction therapy or PCIT. It is magic. It truly is the most magical treatment on the face of the planet. And I can say that because I've got the mic. PCIT has more than 400 scientific journal articles, book chapters, randomized trials on its effectiveness. And we know from many of those studies that it is extremely effective for children who have experienced trauma. Now recently, I've been working with a colleague, Dr. Christina Warner Metzger, another wonderful psychologist to create a trauma module specific to PCIT, to give parents skills and ideas and
当我把视线投向通用心理急救（PFA）之外时，我的特定领域是亲子互动疗法（PCIT）。这太神奇了。它确实是地球上面最神奇的治疗方法。我可以这么说，因为我手里拿着话筒。PCIT 拥有 400 多篇科学期刊文章、图书章节以及关于其有效性的随机对照试验。我们从许多研究中得知，它对于经历过创伤的儿童极其有效。现在最近，我一直在与一位同事合作——克里斯蒂娜·沃纳·梅茨格博士（Dr. Christina Warner Metzger），另一位出色的心理学家——来创建一个专门针对 PCIT 的创伤模块，赋予父母各种技能、理念和
language that they can use when they see their child engaging, for example, in building buildings up and knocking them down in that post-traumatic play. Or they start crying because they're scared because it is storming outside and they've just been through floods. So we've worked on that were in the midst of a multi multiple sites collecting data before we sort of push it out bigger but one of the things that was interesting the very first cohort that we looked at trying this was in new south wales australia and it was a naturalistic study started everybody got into the study because the children had had trauma part way through the study had to put a pen in things because most of the families had to evacuate because of fires that hit New South Wales.
语言，当他们看到孩子从事诸如在创伤后游戏中搭积木然后推倒之类的行为时，他们可以使用这些语言。或者当他们在外面遭遇风暴并且刚刚经历过洪水时，因为害怕而开始哭泣。所以我们一直在致力于此，目前正处于多中心收集数据的阶段，然后才会将其更广泛地推广。但有趣的事情之一是，我们研究尝试的第一个队列是在澳大利亚新南威尔士州，这是一项自然主义研究，每个人之所以能进入这项研究，是因为孩子们曾遭受过创伤。在研究进行到一半时，我们不得不暂停，因为大多数家庭不得不因袭击新南威尔士州的火灾而撤离。
They came back, started up again, had to put a pin in it, floods, came back, started again, COVID. Oh, Lord. So then you start saying, you can't really talk about what's doing what? And what we've learned is this is not unusual. We have done several other places, not as bad as New South Wales, but we're collecting information, and sure enough, they come in with one trauma, and halfway through, we look again, and the majority of kids have had another trauma.
他们回来了，重新开始，又不得不暂停，因为发生了洪水，回来后重新开始，接着又是 COVID。哦，天哪。然后你开始意识到，你真的无法谈论是什么在起作用？我们了解到的是，这并不罕见。我们在其他几个地方也做过，虽然没有新南威尔士州那么糟糕，但我们在收集信息，果然，他们带着一种创伤进来，到了一半我们再看时，大多数孩子又经历了另一种创伤。
And PCT is very short term. It averages around 20 to 25 sessions. So we have to make sure that as psychologists, we don't just start at where we were at the beginning. We keep looking all the way across. And we've looked at PCIT for trauma. We've looked at adapting it for our military during the wars. There were so many families with young children that were deployed. It was creating stress and strain on relationships.
并且 PCIT 是非常短期的。它平均在 20 到 25 次会话左右。因此我们必须确保作为心理学家，我们不能只从我们开始的地方出发。我们要一直持续关注。我们研究过用于创伤治疗的 PCIT。我们研究过在战争期间为我们的军队调整它。有那么多带幼儿的家庭被部署。这给关系带来了压力和紧张。
So we looked at how to improve those relationships. And that's one of the cornerstones of PCIT. Another program that we are trying to gather more and more science behind it, We've got some. I think it's called child-adult relationship enhancement or care. It is similar to MI. You don't send somebody to motivational interviewing therapy, but the tools of MI help make anything you do better.
所以我们研究了如何改善这些关系。那是 PCIT 的基石之一。我们正试图为其收集越来越多的科学依据的另一个项目，我们已经有一些了。我想它被称为“儿童与成人关系增强（CARE）”。它类似于动机式访谈（MI）。你不会把某人送去接受动机式访谈治疗，但 MI 的工具可以让你的任何工作做得更好。
And care is a set of skills based on strong, strong, scientifically backed parenting programs, but it's not therapy. It's a set of skills. and how do we give adults, any adult, from school bus drivers to daycare teachers, to soccer coaches, to parents, to caseworkers for foster children, skills that they can interact with children to make the children feel safe, reduce distress, reduce the need for more intensive treatment. And we're seeing really nice gains from a program that is four hours long. And so we're hoping recently through grant funding as part of the National Child Traumatic Stress Network, we've been able to adopt the care program specifically for disasters.
而 CARE 是一套基于强大、坚实、有科学支持的育儿计划的技能，但它不是治疗。它是一套技能。以及我们如何赋予成年人（任何成年人，从校车司机、日托老师、足球教练、父母到寄养儿童的个案工作者）技能，让他们能够与儿童互动，使儿童感到安全、减轻痛苦、减少对更深入治疗的需求。我们看到一个为期四小时的项目取得了非常好的成效。因此，我们希望最近通过作为全国儿童创伤性应激网络（NCTSN）一部分的拨款资助，我们能够专门针对灾难调整 CARE 项目。
So complementing psychological first aid, complementing skills for psychological recovery. And if they do need that intensive level of treatment, complementing those treatments. And we've now provided respond with care after the, you know, shooting with the Super Bowl celebration in Kansas City to floods in Asheville, North Carolina, to a shooting in East Lansing, Michigan. So many different places, the Highland Park Parade. So we're finding that the uptake has been good because really what parents want to know, what carers want to know, grandparents, teachers, other adults, what do I do?
因此，这可以补充心理急救、补充心理恢复技能。如果他们确实需要那种高强度的治疗水平，这也能作为这些治疗的补充。我们在堪萨斯城超级碗庆祝活动枪击案、北卡罗来纳州阿什维尔的洪水、密歇根州东兰辛的枪击案、海兰帕克游行等事件发生后，都提供了“用关怀回应”（Respond with Care）服务。很多不同的地方。所以我们发现接受度一直很好，因为实际上父母、照顾者、祖父母、老师和其他成年人真正想知道的是：我该怎么做？
What do I do? Give me something I can do to reduce the worries and concerns with my children. Because we have to recognize that the cares are equally distressed. And if I'm distressed, I have a harder time helping my child on their journey after these events. So how do we provide both? And if we add what you talked about at the very beginning, thank you so much because sometimes when we talk disasters, people don't include grief. I mean, to us, we're like, okay, well, of course grief. But that is not what you will typically find. It's not even always collected. And grief is a different thing. I can be resilient. I can bounce back with the right emotional supports, with the right strategies for coping. I can bounce back and move forward. You don't bounce back from grief,
我该怎么做？给我一些我可以做的事情，来减少我对孩子的担忧和顾虑。因为我们必须认识到，照顾者同样承受着痛苦。如果我很痛苦，我在这些事件发生后帮助孩子度过这段旅程时就会遇到更多困难。那么我们如何两者兼顾呢？如果我们加上你在最开始谈到的内容——非常感谢，因为有时当我们谈论灾难时，人们不包括悲伤。我的意思是，对我们来说，我们就像是，好吧，当然有悲伤。但那并不是你通常会发现的。它甚至并不总是被收集。悲伤是另一回事。我可以有抗逆力。通过正确的情感支持，通过正确的应对策略，我可以振作起来并向前迈进。你无法从悲伤中振作起来，
Nor should you. Grief changes us. We learn to heal. So how do we help children heal from grief? How do we help them incorporate that into their new history, their new narrative? And are there special interventions then for dealing with grief where those look like? There are wonderful interventions that are grief specific and those would be at the top of the pyramid. But there are also all these universal and second tier approaches that we can incorporate with a grief lens. How do we superimpose that? How do we talk to families about these are the kind of reactions you are likely to have with grief and your children are going to have some of the same?
你也不应该这么做。悲伤改变了我们。我们学会了治愈。那么我们如何帮助儿童从悲伤中治愈？我们如何帮助他们将这一点融入他们的新历史、新叙事中？那么，是否存在针对处理悲伤的特殊干预措施？那些看起来是什么样的？有一些极好的、针对悲伤的特定干预措施，这些将处于金字塔的顶端。但也有所有这些通用的和第二梯队的方法，我们可以通过悲伤的视角将它们纳入其中。我们如何叠加这一点？我们如何向家庭谈论这些是你在悲伤时可能有的反应，而你的孩子也会有同样的一些反应？
And they overlap quite a bit with basic trauma reactions. So I don't know if the sleep problems are because of grief or because of the sleep problems. the disaster, I just know there's sleep problems and what do we do about it? Right. And so how do we help children understand grief? And I think as we, when we talk about grief to recognize that as children get older, sometimes it creates distancing from peers because I lost my mother and I don't know how to engage with friends who have their mothers or my friends don't talk to me because they don't know what to say to me because I've lost my mother. So just when I need my peers, they're not there. And I go to find support for my family, but they're grieving too.
它们与基本的创伤反应有相当大的重叠。所以我不知道睡眠问题是因为悲伤还是因为灾难，我只知道有睡眠问题，我们该怎么办？没错。那么我们如何帮助儿童理解悲伤？我认为当我们谈论悲伤时，我们要认识到，随着儿童年龄的增长，有时它会造成与同龄人的疏离，因为我失去了母亲，我不知道如何与那些拥有母亲的朋友交往，或者我的朋友不跟我说话，因为他们不知道该对我说什么，因为我失去了母亲。所以正当我需要同龄人时，他们却不在。我去寻求家庭的支持，但他们也在悲伤。
And so we talk to families about everything from what to expect from yourself and to give yourself a little bit of compassion and also how to support your children all the way to do I take my child to a funeral. If it's a community-wide event, it is in the public, eye. And that's a whole different kettle of fish, so to speak, because no two families are going to grieve the same way, yet the spotlight's on them. And yet sometimes the media would really like just one answer, how should all these families manage grief? And they're not the same. Right, right. We're going to take a short break. And when we return, I'll talk to Dr. Gerwitch about how parents can talk to their children about disasters and tragic events.
所以我们与家庭谈论从对自己的期望以及对自己多一点同情，到如何支持你的孩子，一直到我是否应该带孩子去参加葬礼。如果这是一个全社区范围的事件，它就在公众视野中。可以说，这是一个完全不同的难题，因为没有两个家庭会以同一种方式悲伤，然而聚光灯却打在他们身上。然而有时媒体真的很想要一个答案：所有这些家庭应该如何应对悲伤？但它们并不相同。对，对。我们将进行短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我们将与格维茨博士探讨父母如何与孩子谈论灾难和悲惨事件。
in the news. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay, West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply.
在家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠活动中，你的夏天现在就开始了。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅售 199 美元。整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾 (Hampton Bay) West Groves 七件套户外餐饮桌椅招待客人，仅售 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保底低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用除外条款。
see homedepot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room.
详情请参见 homedepot.com/pricematch。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路的了。或者你也可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。
Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. So speaking of media, how do you advise parents and other caregivers to deal with their kids after a tragic event that had a lot of media coverage?
距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，享受你期待的住宿。当你想要省钱而不是惊吓时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。说到媒体，你如何建议父母和其他照顾者在经历了大量媒体报道的悲惨事件后如何应对他们的孩子？
What should they be doing? Sure. I think one of the things that is something we all recognize now is media is 24-7. It never stops. So we strongly encourage that families talk to their children, even if it's not in their community. Right? There was a horrible flood in Texas, and many children died and people lost their lives. Tell me what you've heard about it.
他们应该做些什么？当然。我认为我们现在都认识到的一件事是，媒体是 24 小时全天候的。它永不停歇。因此，我们强烈鼓励家庭与他们的孩子交谈，即使事情没有发生在他们的社区里。对吧？德克萨斯州发生了一场可怕的洪水，许多儿童丧生，人们失去了生命。告诉我你听到了什么。
It was a camp. I mean, kids would know all about that. I'm a camper, and I go and we... camp on the river and now I'm scared. Right. It may be a school shooting. It didn't happen in my community, but my children I'll go to school. And Jonathan Comer, wonderful contributor to APA, did a great study looking at, is it better
那是一个营地。我的意思是，孩子们对此了如指掌。我是一名营员，我去过那里，我们在河边露营，现在我很害怕。对吧。这可能是一起校园枪击案。它没有发生在我的社区，但我的孩子们也要去上学。乔纳森·科默（Jonathan Comer）是 APA 的杰出撰稿人，他做了一项出色的研究，探讨了在波士顿马拉松爆炸案发生后，与孩子们交谈是否更好？
to talk to your children or not after the Boston Marathon bombing? And John and his colleagues found when you talk to children, they're less likely to develop mental health distress than when you don't. So sometimes what we need to do, even if it's outside of our community, is to say this horrible thing happened, tell me what you know about it. That allows you to first listen and hear where are they coming from? And you will hear misinformation because social media also is great grist for rumor mills. But you will have misperceptions, misinformation, misattributions that you can hear and begin to
还是不交谈更好？乔恩和他的同事发现，当你与儿童交谈时，他们出现心理健康困扰的可能性比不交谈时要小。所以有时我们需要做的是，即使它发生在我们的社区之外，也要说：“这件可怕的事情发生了，告诉我你对它了解多少。”这能让你首先倾听并听到：他们的出发点是什么？你会听到错误的信息，因为社交媒体也是流言蜚语的绝佳温床。但你会听到误解、错误信息、错误归因，你可以听到并开始温和地纠正它们。你可以进行了解。
gently correct. You can check in. I feel like a psychologist. How did that make you feel? But we should validate those feelings, not try to talk them out of it. The child says, I'm really, really angry. And we say, oh, you shouldn't feel angry. Then what makes us think they're ever going to talk to us about anything again if you can't validate me?
我觉得自己像个心理学家了：“那让你有什么感觉？”但我们应该验证这些情绪，而不是试图说服他们放弃这些情绪。如果孩子说：“我真的很生气、非常生气。”而我们说：“哦，你不应该感到生气。”那么有什么理由让我们认为他们以后还会就任何事情跟我们交谈呢，如果你连我都无法验证？对吧。
Right. Those are their feelings. They're real. So listen, I think is really important. Make sure that they know you are available to talk to them. But have that conversation. Don't assume that because they're so young, they won't know. That first grader is on a school bus with children that are much older and they're going to be talking about it. It's a kind of inoculation. I mean, what you're doing here is building resilience, right? By getting kids ready, prepared. really talking through disasters even when they haven't touched them personally because children are afraid. They are. They may be angry or they may be worried or they may be anxious or they may be multiple. You know, a big plug to Inside Out movies. It teaches us that you can have more than one emotion at the same time. There's a throwaway line in Inside Out 2 where joy and sadness are talking. and joy tell sadness we will always be together because any time that joy is there, sadness is too.
那是他们的情绪。它们是真实的。所以倾听，我认为真的很重要。确保他们知道你可以随时与他们交谈。但要进行那次对话。不要假设因为他们太小而不会懂。那个一年级小学生正和比他大得多的孩子们坐在一辆校车上，他们会谈论这件事。这是一种接种。我的意思是，你在这里做的是建立抗逆力，对吧？通过让孩子们做好准备。即使灾难没有亲触及他们，也要彻底讨论灾难，因为孩子们会害怕。他们会的。他们可能会生气，或者可能会担忧，或者可能会焦虑，或者可能会有多种情绪。你知道的，对《头脑特工队》（Inside Out）电影的一个大力支持。它教导我们，你可以同时拥有不止一种情绪。《头脑特工队2》中有一句漫不经心的台词，乐乐（Joy）和忧忧（Sadness）在交谈，
And when there's sadness, joy can be there also. And so recognizing there can be multiple emotions that kids will have, but you are exactly right. We're setting the stage. If you can talk to your children about the really hard, ugly stuff, you've just increased the likelihood that they are going to come talk to you when they're feeling peer pressure, when they're disappointed because they didn't make the baseball team, or when they're scared about a book report, or when they're getting pressure to do things that they feel would be uncomfortable.
乐乐告诉忧忧，我们永远会在一起，因为每当乐乐出现时，忧忧也同样会出现。当忧忧出现时，乐乐也可以出现。因此，认识到孩子们会有多种情绪，你是完全正确的。我们正在为之奠定基础。如果你能与你的孩子谈论那些真正艰难、丑陋的事情，你就刚刚提高了这种可能性：当他们感受到同龄人压力时，当他们因为没有入选棒球队而感到失望时，当他们对读书报告感到害怕时，或者当他们面临压力去做那些让他们觉得不舒服的事情时，他们会来找你交谈。
If I can set it up at the very beginning, gosh, my carer will talk about anything with me, I've just increased the likelihood they're going to come to me when those kinds of events occur. So let me switch gears for a minute and ask, how do factors like race, socioeconomic, or disability intersect with trauma, both exposure and recovery? Great question, because I think we do need to go there. Because if we don't talk about it, again, we're not going to be able to understand or address it. We know COVID showed us in neon lights that more. marginalized populations, people of color, people with lower socioeconomic status, were less likely to receive services, have access to services, and they were more likely to have worse outcome from the pandemic.
如果我能在最开始就建立好这一点：“天哪，我的照顾者会和我谈论任何事”，我就刚刚提高了他们在这些事件发生时来找我的可能性。所以让我转换一下话题，问一个问题：诸如种族、社会经济地位或残疾等因素如何与创伤（包括暴露和恢复）交织在一起？这是一个很好的问题，因为我认为我们确实需要探讨这个话题。因为如果我们不谈论它，我们就无法理解或解决它。我们知道新冠疫情（COVID）以霓虹灯般醒目的方式向我们展示了：更多边缘化群体、有色人种、社会经济地位较低的人，获得服务的可能性更低，获得服务的渠道更少，而且他们更有可能从大流行中承受更糟糕的结果。
And we see that oftentimes happening. So we really do need to recognize that, but we also have to recognize that there are cultural issues too that we need to consider. I mean, I've been to Florida, North Carolina, and Tennessee following Haleen. They're very different cultures. If I'm going to L.A. to address things there, they're going to be very different than North Carolina. So we have to take not only ethnic considerations, but culture, where we are, where we are in this country, and we need to to make sure that we are talking to the people from those communities. We need to listen and learn from them so that when we go in to provide support, to provide trainings, to provide
我们看到这种情况经常发生。所以我们确实需要认识到这一点，但我们也必须认识到，我们还需要考虑文化问题。我的意思是，在海伦（Helene）飓风过后，我去过佛罗里达州、北卡罗来纳州和田纳西州。它们的文化截然不同。如果我去洛杉矶解决那里的问题，那将与北卡罗来纳州大不相同。因此，我们不仅要考虑种族因素，还要考虑文化、我们身处何地、我们在该国所处的位置，并且我们需要确保我们正在与这些社区的人们交谈。我们需要倾听他们的心声并向他们学习，这样当我们进去提供支持、提供培训、提供咨询和服务时，我们才能在他们所在的地方与他们会合。
consultation and services, we're meeting them where they are. But yeah, we do see that individuals, that racial differences, SES differences, have different outcomes. It's often because they don't have the same access to services. We also see that there is still, I mean, I would love to say, gosh, we've been doing psychology for a long time. There's no stigma around mental health. That would be a lie. There's still stigma.
但是的，我们确实看到个人、种族差异、社会经济地位（SES）差异会导致不同的结果。这通常是因为他们无法获得相同的服务渠道。我们还看到，仍然存在——我的意思是，我很乐意说：“天哪，我们从事心理学很长时间了。对心理健康的污名化已经不复存在了。”那将是一个谎言。污名化依然存在。
And so we also know that certain groups and minority populations are one that are less likely to avail themselves to mental health services. So how do we better support? One of my colleagues talks about go where they are. If you're working with black communities, go to the barbershops. Don't expect them to come to you. So we need to think about that.
我们也知道，某些群体和少数族裔群体是不太可能利用心理健康服务的群体。那么我们该如何更好地提供支持呢？我的一位同事谈到：“去他们在的地方。”如果你在与黑人社区合作，去理发店。不要指望他们来找你。所以我们需要考虑这一点。
How do we look to make sure we're addressing those concerns? And then I'm sorry, we have to layer on. There are reasons that we may be more hesitant. If I'm black and I think about the long history from the Tuskegee studies to other things, gee, I don't know why I should just trust you. I would go ask for help from you, yeah. So we have to recognize historical trauma plays a role too. So there are multiple factors at play that we need to consider when we are responding. and I have found in a really positive way that because of things like psychological first aid,
我们如何确保我们正在解决这些担忧？然后，抱歉，我们必须叠加一点。我们可能会更犹豫是有原因的。如果我是黑人，回想起从塔斯基吉研究（Tuskegee studies）到其他事情的漫长历史，天哪，我不知道我凭什么应该直接信任你。我怎么会向你寻求帮助呢？是的。所以我们必须认识到历史创伤也发挥着作用。因此，当我们做出反应时，有多种因素在起作用，我们需要加以考虑。而且我以一种非常积极的方式发现，由于诸如心理急救（PFA）之类的事物——
which is just emotional support and strategies for coping, I can sort of help open the door to hear some things that may be helpful down the road. If you still have challenges, here are services that can help you. Yeah. So when I started this podcast, I talked about the increase in disasters we're living through today. And you began this work in 1995, as you said with Oklahoma City. So I just want to close by asking you, are we getting any better at this? I mean, you've learned a lot in all of the years of work that you've done.
这只是一种情感支持和应对策略——我可以某种程度上帮助打开大门，听取一些在未来可能会有帮助的事情。如果你仍然面临挑战，这里有一些可以帮助你的服务。是的。所以当我开始这个播客时，我谈到了我们今天所经历的灾难的增加。正如你所说，你于 1995 年从俄克拉荷马城开始这项工作。所以我只想最后问你一个问题：我们在在这方面做得越来越好了吗？我的意思是，在你所做的大量工作中，你学到了很多。
You've come up with new concepts and therapies. But are they taking hold in the community at large? Are we getting better at helping people through these incidents? I think we are. And yes, I actually believe in climate change, and I think that we are seeing many, many more disasters because of climate change and places that never experienced hurricanes or getting hurricanes or snow or getting snow. I mean, we're topsy-turvy. And we have made such huge strides in disaster mental health. And I think that is one point I would really want to make is disaster mental health is not the same as traditional mental health services.
你提出了新的概念和疗法。但它们在整个社区中站稳脚跟了吗？我们在帮助人们度过这些事件方面做得越来越好了吗？我认为是的。是的，我实际上相信气候变化，我认为由于气候变化以及从未经历过飓风的地方现在正遭受飓风或降雪侵袭，我们正在看到更多、更多的灾难。我的意思是，我们一切都颠倒了。我们在灾难心理健康方面取得了巨大的进步。我认为我想真正指出的一点是：灾难心理健康与传统的心理健康服务并不相同。
So if you are in the mental health field, please seek out training in disaster mental health, what that is like and how you can support survivors after disasters. And disasters is any event that overwhelms an ability for us to cope. So they can be natural terrorism. They can be man-made. they can be whatever. But we've come a long way. There are many, many more treatments across the age span. There are many, many more providers that truly do understand this.
因此，如果你身处心理健康领域，请寻求灾难心理健康方面的培训，了解那是什么样的，以及如何在灾难发生后支持幸存者。灾难是指任何压倒我们应对能力的事件。所以它们可以是自然灾害、恐怖主义。它们可以是人造的。它们可以是任何东西。但我们已经走过了很长的路。跨年龄段的治疗方法已经多得多。有更多、更多的提供者真正理解这一点。
We now have Division 56 of APA, the Trauma Psychology Division, and within that, there's special work being done in disasters. So we have that in APA. That wasn't there a couple of decades ago. So we're making huge, huge strides. And so I think we still have a ways to go. I don't want us to stop. We're looking at, you mentioned, racial disparities.
我们现在拥有 APA 第 56 分会，即创伤心理学分会，在该分会内部，有专门针对灾难开展的工作。所以我们在 APA 中拥有了这一点。这在几十年前是没有的。所以我们正在取得巨大、巨大的进步。因此，我认为我们还有一段路要走。我不想让我们停下来。我们正在关注——你提到了种族差异。
We need to look at religious disparities. Anti-Semitism right now is off the charts. How is that impacting that community's ability to feel safe in the world that they inhabit? So we have to create a bigger tent and invite more people in and really encourage the current generation of psychologists as well as the coming generations of psychologists to enter into the disaster mental health world. It's different, but it is incredibly rewarding. And we as disaster mental health professionals have learned, too, if we're not taking care of, care of ourselves when we're doing this work, we're not going to be much use to anybody. So we've learned a lot about the importance of self-care in this journey over the decades.
我们需要关注宗教差异。反犹太主义现在正呈直线上升。这如何影响该社区在他们所居住的世界中感到安全的能力？所以我们必须建立一个更大的帐篷，邀请更多的人进来，并真正鼓励当前一代的心理学家以及未来一代的心理学家进入灾难心理健康世界。这是不同的，但它是极其有回报的。作为灾难心理健康专业人士，我们也了解到，如果我们在这个过程中没有照顾好自己，我们将对任何人都没有多大用处。因此，几十年来，我们在这个旅程中对自我照顾的重要有了很多了解。
Well, Dr. Gerwit, I want to thank you. And thank you for the very important work that you do. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your. podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，格维茨博士，我要感谢你。也感谢你所做的非常重要的工作。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学说话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学说话》由李·韦内曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会向您问好。本集暂无评论。点击成绩单中的任意句子即可发表评论。